5-6-4 START.
TEAM IN THE NATIONAL A CHANCE.
THERE IS A DRIVE FROM THE RIGHT
HERE.
CANNOT HAVE TURNOVERS LIKE
JOB>
>> THE NET.
THEY BATTLE 212 ON THE WHISTLE
HE W
TAKING IT TO THPOSSESSION ALIVE
ALMOST WRAPPED
PUTS IT IN IT OVER. TH
GETS TO THE GOAL LINE.
PUTS IT OFF HIS LONG WRISTER.
PUTTING BUT
UTILIZING WHERE THE AVAILABLE U
CAPITALIZES OFF THE NEW YORK
RANGERS.
>>
BEAUTIFULLY DONE.
THE RANGERS HAVE A TO READ.
THAT TAKES THREE DEFENDERS E NE
FLIPS IT OUT
HE HAS HAD A ROUGH GO LATELY. L
HAVE SEEN OF THE PERIOD.
HE BRINGS IT ACROSS
WHIPS THE
THIRD.
>> T TON NET.
THAT WAS DIRECTED IN.
A NICE LITTLE TIP CANNOT CLEAR.
IS GETTING AWFULLY CLOSE.
LOOKING FOR A LOOSE PUCK.
THE L
THE SHOT
THE PATIENTLY WAIT.
HE LOOKED LIKE IT KICKED
HE SCORES.
GOAL.
TO BOUNCE OFF